では お経 諸仏経典あげますので
香束つけますか  大師普賢行
すいません 回してください
[仏教のお経]ガンチャンティサンデマナマンチャ
ナマミダンマンムニラジャサワカン
シャントリーサダホントスキーアヴェラ
カヨジグンチョサカローグガンドー
ガンシャンティサンデマナマンアンチャ
ナマミサンガムニラジャサワカン
シャントリーサダホントスキーアヴェラ
カヨジグンチョサカローグガンドー
ガンシャンティサンデマナマンアンチャ
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
生きとし生けるものの悩み苦しみがなくなりますように
生きとし生けるものの願いごとが叶えられますように
生きとし生けるものにも悟りの光が現れますように
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますようにと念じます
生きとし生ける [合唱]はい
これからあの 祝福経典
あの ガンヴィッサル長老と坊さんたちが祝福経典あげます
[合唱][仏教経典]サマーディーナテーナサモーナウィッチャティ
イダンピダンメーラタナンパニータンエーテーナサッチャーナスーアッティホーツー
エープッグララーッタサタンパサッタージャッターエーターニユガーニホントリーテーダッキネッヤーシュガラタッササーヴァカーエーテーシュディンナーニマハッパラニー
イダンピサンゲーラタナンパニータンエーテーナサッチャーナスーアッティホーツー
エー suppa ユッターマナサーダウェーナニッサーミノゴータマサーサナンエーテーパッティパッターアマタングイガイヤラッタームダーニッブティムクンジャマー
ナー
イダンピサンゲーラタナンパニータンエーテーナサッチャーナスーアッティホーツー
ヤティンダキーローパタウィンシトーシヤジャトゥッディワーテービヤサンパカンピヨー
タトゥーパマングサップリサンワダーミーヨー
アリーヤサッチャーニアウェッチャパッソテー
イダンピサンゲーラタナンパニータンエーテーナサッチャーナスーアッティホーツー
エーアリーヤサッチャーニヴィーバーワヤンテーガンビーラパンネーナシュデーシェターニキンチャーピケーホントリープサッパマッターラテーバワンアッタマンアーディヤンテー
サーヴァッサダーッサナサンプダーヤタヤッスダンマジャリターバワンティーサッガーヤディッティウィチキッチタンチャ
シーラッバサンワーピアダッティキンチー
タトゥーアッバーエーイチャウィッパムットーチャチャーヴィターナーニアバッボーカートー
イダンピサンゲーラタナンパニータンエーテーナサッチャーナスーアッティホーツー
キンチャーピソーカンマンカローティパーパカンカーエーナワーチャウダチェータサーヴァアバッボーソータッサパティッチャーダーヤアバッバターディッッタパダッサウッター
アナッパグンベーアタープッシタッゲーキンマーナマーセーパタマッスィンギンネー
タトゥーパマングダンマバランアデーサエーニッバーナガービンパラマンイターヤ
イダンピブッデーラタナンパニータンエーテーナサッチャーナスーアッティホーツー
ワローワランヨーワラトーワラーローワヌットターローダンマバランアデーサエー
キーナンプーラナンナワンナッティサンバワンウィラッタチッターヤティケーバヴァスミンテーキーナビージャーウィルッリッチャンダーニッバンディディーラーヤターヤンパディーポー
イダンピサンゲーラタナンパニータンエーテーナサッチャーナスーアッティホーツー
ヤーニイダブーターニサマーガターニブッマーニワーヤーニワアンタリカエータターガタンデーワマヌッサプージタングブッダンアマスーマースーアッティホーツー
ヤーニイダブーターニサマーガターニブッマーニワーヤーニワアンタリカエータターガタンデーワマヌッサプージタングダンマンアマスーマースーアッティホーツー
ヤーニイダブーターニサマーガターニブッマーニワーヤーニワアンタリカエータターガタンデーワマヌッサプージタングサンガンアマスーマースーアッティホー
[仏教経典][仏教経典]サッダ
じゃあこれそれぞれ一人一人で巻いていって回しちゃえば簡単です
これ回れ--回れますから
それ  [笑い]じゃああんたはちらねって
これくるんでから糸を最後に
それ回転しますから簡単にできますよ
[笑い] 法要という感じでね
まあ明日は普通のお祭りという感じにはいたしますか
どちらでも縋らなきゃ
苦労しなきゃ成り立たないものだからね
こちらのこういう法要活動などなどはずっとあのまだまだ独立してできなくできなくなってるんだからね
ずっと正信寺のお坊様方に依存してやってますので
心からあのダンメスレ観音様と正信寺の唐土とお坊様方に感謝いたします
どうもありがとうございます
何もアイデアはないんだけどね
まあ一応それだけで 何かウェーサーカに対して聞きたいことがございますか
この五月あたりに来るのは
おそらくお釈迦様の誕生か成道
どちらかだとは思いますね
涅槃に入られた日にちは
五月にはちょっと計算すると当たらないんですね
それでお釈迦様が生まれる時はそんなに知られていなかったんだから
おそらくウェーサーカの満月はお釈迦様が解脱に達した日ではないかなとね
と省略して考えることはできます
お釈迦様との違うところはね
完全に人間に幸福を与えるんですね
で だから幸福っていうのは
一人一人がね 自分の心のエネルギーがあってね
心が回転するんだから
その回転する心はどのように回転するのかっていうことなんですよ
物質に依存しているのも心でしょうし
だからどんな程度で物質に依存するのか
物質に潰れてしまうのか
物質を支配して動くのかどうかね
それは心の力次第なんですよ
だから我々がいろいろ考えてみると
自分と物質の関わりはどんな風になっているのかっていうことは簡単にわかりますね
自分の体には結構依存していますけど
この依存しているこの物体がうまく作動しない場合はね
結構心が大変やられますよ
歩きたいと思っても歩けないとかね
動きたいと思って動けないとかね
あるいは何か体に障害あるとかね
まあそういう場合はこの
心がすごく不幸を感じちゃうんですね
自由がないんですからね
そこでまたいろんな人の心はね
まあ自分の肉体物体だけじゃなくて
周りの物体も支配管理して抑えて
まあいろんなことをやったりはするんですね
それで他人まで 世の中の他の物質まで自分が支配しているっていう風な
その分かなり苦労しなくちゃいかんですよ
一人が 例えば自分の土地を持っているならばね
その分体心が苦労しなくちゃなんです
土地の大きさによって
どんどん 精神的な安らぎがなくなっていくんですね
で そういうことで 持つものが増えれば増えるほど安らぎか苦しみかっていうこともね
まあ一概に安らぎって言わない
言えないし 一概に苦しいとも言えないんだけど
まあそのその人の心次第なんですね
で 心はすごく無知がすごく強くなっちゃうと
ものすごくもう物事にしがみすぎて
自分のものにとろうと無理をやるんですね
その無理をやる分はそううまくいかないんだから
結構疲れる 苦しんでしまうんですね
もっとわかりやすい例で言えばね
例えばあの古い 何かすごい珍しい品物があるという壺でも掛け軸でも何でもいいんですね
で すごい値打ちのある
ものが自分の財産としてあると
それでその人は幸せ感じるか
不幸感じるか 怯えるか
悩んでしまうか その人の心次第なんです
で 自分にはまあ日本でもたった一品しかない
すごいもう 億単位で値打ちのある大事なものを自分は持っているということで喜び感じることもできる
あるいはその品物の奴隷になっちゃって
守るは守るは守るは守るはね
あらゆる工夫をして それがもう長く壊れないように保存するように
これに苦労して 別な収入もない
それでもこれ 24時間空気管理して
湿度を管理して 温度を管理して
また誰かにとらわれないように警備システム管理して
しかしそこをやるお金もないし
収入もないし その人がそれで苦労するんです
だからそれは誰かにあげちゃってね
清々した方がいいのに
執着あれば誰もできないんですね
あげませんと あるいはまああまりもういいやという感じで置いておいて
面倒くさいやと それで誰かに盗まれたら
もう大騒ぎして この丸ごと
もうどういうことかとかね
それでまたその人がそれによって苦しみを感じなくちゃいかんですね
とにかくそうやって心次第ですね
全部 だから世の中でいう
このお金があったら幸せやとかね
そういう感じがないんですよ
家があったら幸せやとかね
全て心次第なんですね
だからお釈迦様がこの心の弱みを教えてるんだからね
心はどのように苦しみのかと教えてるんだから
それから心にこのエネルギー
よりエネルギーがあってね
楽に活動できるようにする方法やらね
教えているんですね この善行為っていうのはそういうことで
孤独を積むというね ことは自分の心を強くすることなんです
で これは運動をやったからといってね
マラソンやったからって心が強くならないんですね
だから心はどこで弱くなってるのかということも
ブッダしか教えてないんですね
だから心は執着があると弱いんですね
執着あるっていうのは
その物質から離れないという弱みでしょう
だから物質は離れていきますね
で ものすごく嫌になるんですね
離れていって欲しくないのに離れていくんだと
で 執着あるとこれで苦しむんです
執着なかったらそんなのはどういうことだと
例えば親はすごい財産を持っていて
あれが亡くなったら自分が相続するでしょ
そう簡単じゃないんですね
すごい昔私は知っていたんだから
この幡ヶ谷じゃなくて
この 隣の国ですけど もうだからすごい金持ちばっかりいたんですね
でっかい家 家とかびっくりする
何県でしたっけ？渋谷区の隣でしたけどね
うん はい うん 世田谷 そう
当時で まあ家と土地計算しても
まあ十五億とかね 百億とか
すごい テレビでも紹介するんですよ
全部もう豪邸で どうなったかって
その持ち主の方々はお年でしたから
一人一人死んでいっちゃったんですね
そしたらあの相続する人々にはあれを税金払えないんですね
なんとかせえ それで全部売り出さなくちゃいけない
それで切って切って 家も潰して
土地を売って 売って なんとか自分がほんのちっちゃなところで土地を持って
小さい家を造って で 親が
すごい派手に王様気分でいたんだけど
息子に娘にはそれできない
そこでわかるでしょ 物事は自分のものにならないね
しかし 執着あったならば
この家は売りたくないとかね
自分でもこんな贅沢な生活したいと
政府がね 相続税払いなさいと
相続税は億円と 自分が千万しか持ってないよとかね
払わなかったら まあ政府はそれを売りに出しますね
はい だからまあそういうことで
その贅沢のこの豪華な家あったところは全部なくなっちゃったんです
はい 今もあの このこちらコンビニの前にね
前から私すごくいい家だなと
古い家でね 土地もあって
ものすごい大きい木もいっぱいあってね
看板も書いてあった 渋谷区が保存しているんです
その木とかはね それぐらい価値あるものがあって
誰が住んでるでしょうかと興味もあったんだけどね
一応すごい古いもの 建物で
古い日本の家で またでっかい家でね
なんとなく行ったり来たりすると見ると楽しいんですね
自分のものじゃないんだけど
楽しむことは禁止できないでしょ
だからバカが私のものでなきゃ楽しめないと思ってるんだからね
私のものでなくても 見て結構かっこいいねとかね
喜ぶことはできますよ
でもその持ち主たちが亡くなったでしょうね
それで売りに出して あの保存している木は全部抜いちゃって
もう痛み感じるんですよ
何のことをするのかといってマンション作って
作ったばっかしだから
いくらか綺麗に見えるんだけどね
あの潰す 潰したい家ほど
あの なんとなく価値がないんですね
だからまあそうやって見るうちに物質は変わっていく
それで人は悩むのか 楽しむのか
不幸を感じるのか 幸福感じるのかっていうことは
人の心次第ですね だから
物に執着したことは違反であるとブッダが教えるんですね
それはあんた 生命の憲法破ったと
生命 生命の憲法っていうものはないんだけど
これを法と言うんですけどね
法は法式ともなるしね
それを破ったら もうものすごい大変なことになるんです
法則に従うのであって
破ることはできない だから
これは私の土地と言った時点で間違いなんですね
そこから苦しみが生まれるんですよ
だからこの仏教で このあれ
何でしたっけ？孤独を積む
善行為をするという働きの中では
全て心理学的な働きなんです
心を直していくんです
お布施をするということは
まあこれ これはこのものを建ててもらうために行っているインチキじゃないんです
お布施するっていうことは
執着 執着を減らすことなんですね
だから お布施する場合は何をするのかというと
私のものは私のものと思っている
いうものをお布施するんです
私のものだったらお布施できないはずですね
お布施できたのは 本当は私のものではなかったんですね
我々スリランカでよくお母さんたちに出家する場合は
まあ能力ある性格のいい子供たちを見つけたら
我々はなんとなく出家させたくはなるんです
子供の頃から出家しないと間に合わないんです
年取って出家しても 仏教には何の役にも立たない
ですから このすっごいたくさんことを学ばなくちゃいけないんですね
それは普通の教育システムと同じく
中学生ぐらい年齢から始めないと間に合わないんです
二十歳  二十三  二十四になってくると
一年前の坊主になってないと
しかし 一番可愛い年齢の子供はくれるわけないでしょう
で 子供を捨てなさいよと
これだけでもあなたにはものすごく早く母親に父親に解脱に達することはできるできますよと
それってお坊さんってあまり理解してないんだけど
そこはその通りですよ
我が子にほど愛着 執着はないでしょう
いくらなんでも それははい
どうぞと もうこれから我が子ではないと
この縁を切る だからそこはなんですごい孤独になりますかというと
すごい執着を切っちゃったんです
だから 母親が普通の仏教の普通の信者さんのおばさんとして
あの人に接近しなくちゃいかんですね
我が子ではなくなったんですね
だから まあそれはまあ
仏教の込みでしかできない出来事ですけど
だからこの心は不幸になって悩み
はみ出るのは心にある汚れで
それ一つ一つがまとめると執着ということになりますから
だからブッダがそういうことを教えたんだから
ブッダがずっと幸福を教えてるんです
幸福を実現させてるんです
他の宗教では もう祈る祈る祈る祈るたびに欲が増える増える
執着が増える増える でもその通りにはならないしね
だから苦しみが増えるだけで
すごくリラックスした状態で全部捨てて去るものだという感じで生きることが
ものすごく幸福なんですね
ですから ブッダの教えをまさにしたっても
威張るためでもなく だからお釈迦様を大事に思うことでも
我々はブッダに感謝したことにもなるし
そこでその法要をしたりも
やっぱり心は軽らかになるように設定してされてはあるんですね
そういうことで 心の汚れをいかになくすのかという理由は
心は汚れていると苦労しか悩み
苦しみしか生まれない
この間瞑想会やったんだけど
ある男性が来てね  話したんだけど
本当に その時私もなんかもう
何と言いますか 実感で感じたんですね
この執着がどれほど人に苦しみを与えるのかと
まあそれも子供の問題なんですけど
だからよく話聞いてみるとね
まあ本人は何もしない
黙って耐えているんだけど
すごい苦しんでいるんですね
想像もできないほど悪い子なんですね
考えてみたら そこで私はね
これはいくら見ても この人は精神的にずっと病気で
もう人間には戻らないんだと
だからそういう治療の方に回して回してくださいと
どうにもならんやと 本人が自分を人間であるこの幸せな瞬間の機会を壊しちゃってるんだと
もう戻れない でも親としてそれ考えることはものすごい苦しいでしょう
だから捨てられないでしょう
いくら年取っていても
ずっと面倒見なくちゃいけない
別に体の問題って何もない
頭がイカれてるだけに
だから そこで私 やっぱりね
この方々はね ものすごいこの執着で苦しんでいる
だからといって はいとポイと捨てることもできない
自分の子供だからね だから
私それを教えてあげたんですね
本人に言っても答えはやっぱり家にいくら暴れまわって
いろんな悪いことをやっても
言ってもね 無執着の心でいられればありがたいんだけど
難しいんですよ だからこの不幸を作るのは心なんです
時々解決できない問題にもぶつかったりする
問題を解決できない場合は悩むは悩むは悩む
だからいくら悩んでも問題は解決できんだからね
そこで私のものは何一つもないということで理性を作らなくちゃいけないですね
だから私の土地といっても
本当は私の土地じゃない
私の体といっても 本当は私の体じゃない
そういう風にこの私のと言ったところで
我々は法則を犯しているんですね
法則を犯しちゃうとものすごく苦しむんですね
そのように感じで お釈迦様が我々に
皆様があまり人気のないブッダの教えかもしれませんだけど
ブッダが生命の科学を教えたんですね
科学授業はそんなに漫才みたいに面白くないかもね
しかし仕方がないんです
理解するしかないんですね
だから世の中行ってる道が幸福の道じゃないんですよ
執着のせいですごい残酷なことを起こるということは
今 今 今のこの瞬間にも
世の中でどこでも起きているんです
私の国とか思ったら やれやれ死ななくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんです
今 ネットニュース見るとそればっかりでしょう
これで見ると まああの見てないんだけど
一回二回見ても これは同じ画像を繰り返し繰り返し繰り返し出して人を苦しませるんですね
[no audio]だからこれは狙ってやってるんですね
NHK は  NHK なんかすごい恨み持ってるみたいです
日本人に対して ちょっとだから他の民間は
まあちょっと笑って楽しんでふざけてふざけてもらえばいいんじゃないかなと
まあそれで終わりですけどね
NHK はそうじゃない
北朝鮮のこと出すと あの人の一番気持ち悪い画像だけとって
それだけ繰り返し繰り返し流すんですよ
プーチンさんの顔を出すと
プーチンさんが一番凶暴な恐ろしい人間であるような
ちょっと撮られてるビデオクリップあるんですよ
それしか流さないです
だからいかに人を苦しませるのかっていうことしか考えてないんですね
役に立つ情報ないです
苦しめと泣けと恨み持てと
とにかく基本的に執着があると起こる出来事やと
私のものって何もないのに
そう思った時点で人間がすごく苦しむことになるんです
うん まあそこでまあブッダは人間にこの心清らかにしろね
サチッタパリヨダパナ
だから私は毎日唱えるようにしているんです
自分の心の汚れを落としなさいと
私の子供もいないし 私の家もないし
私の体でもないんですね
ちょっと見たらその通りでしょう
体って自分言うことを聞いてくれたことあるんですかね？一度もない
私たちは体言うことを聞いてあげろ
聞いてあげろ 情けないでしょう
自分の思いにならない物質は自分のものやと思っちゃって
その勘違いのせいで物質が指令する通りに生きているんですね
子供が指令するように
指令に合わせて親が活動する
体が指令するように自分が生きてみる
結果としてひどい苦しみが
しか生まれませんしね
だから私の体と思ったら体が壊れると超気分いい？気分いいわけないでしょう
病気だとこれ治らないんだとかね
あれこれ言うとショックになっちゃうんです
ですから 自分の体見てこの物体が壊れているんだよと
堂々と言える人間出したらどうですかね
あんたはもう癌でもうかなり時間経っちゃってもうお手
おくれ  お手上げ  手上げておくれと言われたらショックを受けるのは執着あるからなんですね
ああ そうですか この機械壊れてるんですかね
じゃあ処分するしかないねとかね
処理できない あ わかった
自分が知ったことじゃないんだと
すれば楽ちんでしょう
ですから どうせ体壊れるんです
どうしても壊れるものは壊れないようにするっていうのは苦しいでしょ
川が流れる 流れはどうやって止めますかね
流れ止めようと思った瞬間から膨大な苦しみがそこで待っているのです
そこでバカがあらゆるあらゆる工夫して川を一旦止めてもらっても
川がまたすぐ流れ始めるんです
いくらダム作ったからといって意味がないんです
そういうことで いかに無執着の心でいるのか
いかに清らかな心でいるのか
いかに常に安穏でいるのかっていうことはブッダの道なんですね
はい そういうことで話は以上です
頑張ってください えーとですね
まあ終わりです 回向の文唱えますかね
それからお坊さんたちがあの
糸 祝福の糸を授けております
はい 回向の文いたします
回向の文 あらゆる生命に憐れみをもって真理を説かれた本師釈迦牟尼佛陀の聖なる教えに従い
我々がここまで積んだすべての功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
お主をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって 生きとし生けるものすべてが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱を得られますように
サンビトイワンジャントーサンベローホーイナッサトーマーテーババッタンターラーヨーシュキーティーガーユコーバヴェーアーユラーローキェサンパッティーサッ
ビェサンパッティメーヴェッジョーアトゥーニンラーナサンパッティーミナテーヘーサミッジョトー
サッザサッザサッザ  それではこれから祝福の糸とお水を皆様にお配りいたしますので
準備ができるまでしばらくお待ちください
まあ一応あの今日の法要はそれで終了です
後片付け終わったら終わりです
どうぞ皆様 お坊様の前に
それぞれのお坊様の前に一列にお並びいただきまして
祝福の糸とお水をお受けください
明日は中野ゼロ小ホールにてウエサカ祭の記念式典がございます
ぜひ多くご参加いただいてご希望ます
本日はどうもありがとうございました
[背景雑音]